- Hi everyone.
So last year I made a video
about India's JEE Advanced exam,
but I don't think that
I really did it justice.
So for this video,
I wanted to invite some experts
in science and engineering
to share their thoughts on the exam.
They spoke about the
difficulty of the questions,
whether they thought the exam
would prepare students well
for the future, and also
shared their thoughts
on exams, as a whole.
I also spoke to a couple of
Indian students who took the JEE
and are now doing research
work here in Australia.
For those not familiar,
the JEE exam is an admissions exam
into engineering colleges,
and it's set by over a million students
competing for just a few thousand places.
You sit two papers, each three
hours long on the same day,
and it's all multi-choice.
So with that, let's hear what
people had to say about it.
(smooth jazz music)
- I think this is a,
it's a very tough exam.
So if I was a student at high school,
and if this was intimidating,
when you first read it,
I would not be surprised.
And if it's not at all
intimidating for you,
then I would say congratulations,
'cause you're a very
impressive kid. (chuckles)
- Well, it's really, really interesting.
- It looks pretty difficult.
For example, the question in physics,
I know I, couldn't probably
can't answer, you know,
maybe most of it now.
Though, maybe 30 years back, I could do.
- You know, these exams seem you know,
they're very long, they
have a very wide variety
of questions they cover and they're hard.
I think any student who
comes up against these exams
is gonna feel pretty
lousy by the end of it.
- I'd probably you know
leave the exam room crying
if I was in year 12 and had to do this.
Yeah.
Good luck, good luck. (laughing)
(smooth jazz music)
- So when we compare this JEE exam
with some of the subjects
that are taught here
in some of our universities in Australia.
So here is a question
that I was looking at,
the depth of, questions that are asked
can be one difficult for students
in the first or second
year who are studying
in a bachelor level in Australia.
- It's really quite ambitious
that they're trying to test
chemistry, and physics, and math,
and the paper is laid out fairly nicely
in that you have to earn
one mark per minute.
Looking at the questions,
a lot of them are in some
sense, sort of elementary
in the sense that they use
the kind of math taught in high schools.
Although in some areas, I would
say the syllabus in calculus
and a couple of other
areas, go somewhat beyond
what is currently taught
in Australian schools,
or currently examined
in Australian schools.
But a lot of the questions
are basically tricky,
or slightly sneaky, but
also don't necessarily
require you to work through
the question in full detail.
It was multiple choice questions.
You have to simply decide,
can I reject this possibility or not?
There is some attempt to
stop people gaming that way
by applying penalties
to some wrong answers,
but still it's very much
a race against the clock.
- I think the mathematic
questions are clever.
It looks for the person's
understanding of the matter,
just rather than doing
some direct questions.
So in that sense, I,
you know, they're okay,
they can be done.
And you know, some of these concepts
I do even use in my course
here in Master schools here,
especially those involved with
a system of linear equations
and determinants and those concepts.
- So concepts like high spin and low spin,
you know again are complex.
That's something that at
the university of Melbourne
in first year chemistry we
would treat in second semester.
There was a question on
essentially Arrhenius equation.
So rates of, a rate of
reaction as a function of,
free energy, of the keeps free energy.
So here we go.
It asks you something like
the activation energy,
the backward reaction exceeds
that of the forward reaction by 2RT.
So again you've got, basically
I think you you'd have to,
sketch this out.
You'd have to think about,
okay, if the back reaction
is exceeding the forward reaction,
what's the reaction free energy?
So it's not just the
concepts that are difficult.
I think it's asking you in a
way that is, that is tricky.
You have to think about,
it's not just enough to know the equation
and you know, throw in the numbers.
You've got to think about
it before you get the number
that you're throwing into the equation.
And obviously, and they're not letting you
have a calculator,
so I guess (laughing)
another challenge there.
(smooth piano jazz)
- Definitely this will set up a basic,
like a background and a baseline.
So you could imagine
that all the IIT students
who have come with, they would
have had from fundamentals.
But from then onward there
are so many things to learn,
because after you come to IITs
there is still, you know,
only it will be like a bell curve, again.
You know, for example,
you give an exam to a,
you know, a very tough exam,
and choose the best in the world
and then give them them another exam.
And still, again,
the performance is
going to be like a bell.
But this happened to be,
this is kind of something
that is, it's kind of basically needed,
basic foundations for engineering.
But I would guess, nearly
the majority of them
would be ready to do
for, you know, go for,
especially general education.
And that, explains why, for example,
IIT students are you know,
IIT graduates are doing
well out on the world.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I had to look at a
couple of the one-hour
math sections of papers.
And I would say I would
be fairly challenged to,
to get a decent result
on those, in an hour.
Partly because as a
professional mathematician,
I'm interested in
actually telling a story,
when I answer a problem.
I want to lay out
why the answer I'm
producing is the answer.
Simply being able to say
well the answer is 27,
to me is not so helpful or so interesting.
And in terms of future success
in mathematics or indeed in
many scientific disciplines,
the ability to reason properly,
and to explain your reasoning clearly
is terribly, terribly important.
So while I have no reason to believe,
that using the exam the way it's used,
isn't selecting very bright students
for the engineering colleges
that they're going to.
It's not clear to me that it's
the optimal selector of that.
And there is also the ugly question of,
of coaching and unequal
access to resources.
We all know that in
any educational system,
if you go to a good school,
well-resourced with the best
teachers and so on like that,
you expect a better outcome.
That's ultimately the main
justification for spending money
on education as a society,
that if you work harder at it,
you produce better results.
But with these race against
the clock style examinations,
there's a trade-off
between the students'
ability in the subject,
natural intelligence and
other things like that.
And they're having been trained
to do a bit examinations of this type.
- Exams can have different
purpose and entry exams
that are sort of in a form
of a drill type of questions,
usually require students to prepare
a lot before to practice.
Brain is like any other muscle,
the more you practice
it, the better it gets.
So when you have a large pool
of candidates and only small
number of spaces,
usually have drill exams,
because what they're showing
is whether the candidate
is serious enough,
whether they're able to practice,
and how they perform on the time limited,
pressured environment conditions.
They're not necessarily a
prediction whether that candidate
will then do very well in
the next step of education.
- So right now I have,
I know two students who
from India's technology,
one from Delhi, other, from a Madras.
So right now they are here in (mumbles)
applying AI, artificial intelligence,
and deep learning techniques
for medical application.
So this work, they're able
to do within, you know,
certain of time.
They demonstrate their skills and ability.
(smooth jazz music)
- Maybe a train is moving at
this velocity, at this speed,
we need to consider,
is it really possible?
Is it feasible?
And then there are
questions about experience.
Have I actually seen a wide
variance, more or less of this?
Is it possible?
- Yeah, experience.
Is this really possible?
So those type of questions
actually come from experience.
So we actually have to try out
various experiments in lab.
You have to know that what
exactly are the ranges,
a practicality that exists in science.
- Two marks or maybe half
mark can change your rank
by great amount, it's possible.
Like, I think minus two
marks can decrease the rank
by 200 or 400.
So you need to be very
careful about how to attempt,
which question to attempt
and you need to be very sure
about it, attempt question.
- Maybe you have for other students
that are preparing for JEE,
feel that being open-minded
is what would really help right now.
All those that are thinking
of maybe starting in class 10, or nine.
I feel that they need to be open-minded.
They need to be considering that yes,
experience in lives are very
important, apart from studies.
I feel that those
experience can really help,
not only in JEE, but also in life.
And yeah, enjoying life is
very important, with studies.
- One of my thing would be,
don't be scared of the exam
hall, examination hall.
So I've experienced that
in JEE, that's not good.
So be open, be free,
whatever you're studying,
just pretend to think and yeah,
all the rest, all happens.
(smooth jazz music)
- Yeah. So when I looked through it,
there was a lot of the questions that,
they are based very much
on this sort of principle
of memorization and recitation,
which I think is just
an extraordinarily bad
educational tool because it assumes
that everyone has the exact
same capabilities in that area.
And as someone who never had a
great memory for these things
and had to work extra hard.
and then became a professional
physicist for over a decade,
you realize very quickly
that those particular skills
don't help you much at all,
once you're actually
working as a scientist
because you know,
scientists get to the point
where the material they're working with
is so complicated, you
just don't remember.
No one could remember it.
So that, skill of
memorization and recitation
is not as helpful as people might think.
In science you know, you tend
to not be successful every day
of your working career.
In fact, quite the opposite.
You tend to, you know, not get
anywhere for quite a while.
I mean, you'll have one lucky day
where something will
occur and your training
will allow you to see that
and identify it as being special.
And that's what makes a good scientist,
but for the other 360
odd days of the year,
you'll have a pretty rough time.
And those sorts of skills,
those sorts of resilience skills,
and understanding how
science and engineering work,
you know the process of falsification
is not something that is tested at all
in these sorts of examinations.
And, it's unfortunate
because you want people
with those skills more than
you want people with skills
with memorization capabilities.
- When I looked at the
JEE math, the maths exams,
it led me to recall an interesting article
by the great British
mathematician, G. H. Hardy.
Indian viewers of this blog,
will perhaps be well
acquainted with Hardy,
who is generally regarded as responsible
for bringing the great Indian
mathematician, Ramanujan
to the attention of the world.
And so Indian viewers should
have some affection for Hardy.
You have to understand that
when Hardy was a young man
and through the early
stages of his career,
mathematical education
in the United Kingdom
was governed by the
Mathematical Tripos examination
for Cambridge undergraduates.
This was a highly competitive examination.
An examination of great difficulty,
in the sense that it
required a large amount
of preparation and training,
paying for professional
coaching, and so on like that.
And on the basis of your Tripos result,
this could lead to academic possibilities,
but also to high positions
in the British Civil Service
and the Colonial Office
and things like that.
In fact, it was viewed generically
as some kind of way of detecting
deep intellectual superiority
and ranking people.
And Hardy didn't have much time for that.
Hardy was actually quite
a fan of examinations
and quite a fan of lecturing, as I am.
And this is unfashionable these days.
What he was not comfortable
with was the Tripos,
particularly in the first version,
in which he encountered it.
In order for the exam
to work the way it did,
a kind of culture had built up,
in terms of the setting of the questions,
the kinds of questions,
and so on like that.
And most of these had very
little to do with mathematics
that was either practically used
or intellectually interesting,
or anything recent in mathematics.
It was basically playing certain games.
The examiners would try and
set slightly sneaky questions
on certain topics, and students would hope
to have practiced lots of questions
of a vaguely similar type
in the hope that they
could get through this.
And Hardy saw this,
as actually warping mathematical education
in the United Kingdom.
So Hardy's argument was,
examinations of the Tripos style
are not a very good way to
rank people intellectually,
and therefore perhaps,
one might consider doing
things differently.
It would be drawing a long bow to claim
that the JEE Advanced Examination
suffers from the defects of the Tripos.
Nonetheless, there are
elements of analogy there,
particularly the issue
of expensive coaching
and the diversion of students
away from studying subjects
and developing their abilities,
and instead teaching them to
do certain kinds of questions
at great speed, which is not actually,
something of great use either
in the practical applications
of mathematics in the real world,
or in academic mathematics,
scientific research or scholarship.
(smooth jazz music)